I was like oh my God what am I going to
do and I was like binging Orange is the
New Black because my friend uzo was on
it and I was like oh my God it's so cool
and like all like everything was
plastered orange was black all over the
subway and everything I was like it's so
cool that she landed the show everyone's
like amazing in it like the writing's so
cool like everyone's acting their faces
off and I was watching it and then I
click into my email and I see an
audition for Orange is the New Black and
I thought it was like hallucinating yeah
you're like all the time like that seems
too I was in the middle of watching so I
was like oh my God no oh my God oh my I
have to like nail this if I don't nail
this I'm going to be so mad at myself
because I like had envisioned myself
doing it in certain ways and oddly this
is maybe TMI but like I had envisioned
certain scenes me filming certain scenes
in it and I ended up doing them oh my
God crying in the shower which ended up
happening me like floating in a lake
which ended up happening oh my God are
you like part
this psychic